people ask me about our church often
about what denomination it is what
traditions at five
is it in this category of church or that
category of church and I have to say
it's really hard to say come and see
what I can say about us is that we do
our best to love God and love Jesus and
love each other we try to make our
worship beautiful and intelligent we try
to live out god's love by helping our
neighbors here in New Haven I can't
promise that we're perfect because we're
certainly not and we will probably
disappoint you at some point but we will
love you and we will be honest with you
so try it out for a few weeks but i'll
let you know it has worked for
innumerable students over the years but
enough introduction and on to the sermon
that's i hope what you came for i want
to begin with a strange moment i had
this week in my office and it may only
be on yale computers but have you ever
noticed in that long long wait after you
turn on your computer at the beginning
of the day and you're waiting for
Microsoft Outlook to open and waiting
and waiting and waiting it may just be
the Yale frame but it really takes
forever and you're fidgeting and you're
tapping your fingers and the little
message comes across the screen and it
says setting up identity I have no
technical sense what outlook thinks it
is doing as it sets up my identity but I
thought it was an interesting metaphor
for what we're doing as we begin college
setting up an identity because for
perhaps for the first time in your life
you're surrounded by people who don't
already know you don't already know your
family don't know your big brother or
big sister don't know your
accomplishments and your mistakes so you
have the option to set up an identity
here at Yale I once heard a story about
a young woman from Plains Georgia and
only the older folks will know that town
she was named Sarah and she went to a
college small liberal arts college in
north
carolina and when she arrived her home
eights saw her hometown listed in the
Facebook and they immediately connected
her with another famous native of Plains
Georgia former President Jimmy Carter so
they asked her do you know President
Carter who's still alive and still
flying around the world and she faced a
difficult decision she'd never really
met Jimmy Carter even though it's a
small town she'd seen him at big
gatherings but she'd never talked to him
one-on-one but she was a shy young woman
and didn't have that many special
qualities or accomplishments to talk
about and didn't want to disappoint her
new friends on her Hall so she said sure
I know him I've talked to him a lot he
comes over to our house and from there
over the weeks the story grew soon she
was telling people she took care of
Carters dog that the former president
had helped her with a school paper and
so on and so on this was her claim to
fame and soon it sounded like she was
almost related to him but three months
later to her horror she saw a poster
that said that President Carter was
coming to campus to speak about peace in
the Middle East and her home ate saw the
posters and started talking started
asking when they were going to meet him
her friend President Carter and could
they come along to the lecture and
perhaps she could have him come up to
their hall and talk to them and have
cookies she thought maybe today is the
right day to drop out of college or
maybe I can develop malaria before next
week or simply just disappearing the day
that the president came to campus but
the day came and she had no good plan
for getting out of it except hoping the
Carter would be too busy but a she and
her whole Hall were trooping into the
lecture hall all of them expecting her
to introduce them to the president
suddenly adoro
buttons on to the hallway that they are
walking down and there is President
Carter with the president of the college
walking to the lecture hall and one of
her more excitable classmates runs up to
Carter and says hey here's your old
friend Sarah from planes and she points
to Sarah and Carter turns of course ever
gracious with a smile on his face and
Sarah tentatively steps forward she said
later she was ready to die ready to melt
ready to vomit anything to get away but
Carter was walking up to her and all her
friends would learn that she was a big
fat liar and her life in college would
be over Carter hesitated for half a
moment and Sarah could see the wheels
turning in his head trying to figure out
who she was and then he opened his arms
and gave her a big hug and said Sarah
how wonderful to see you again how are
you and her friends eyes lit up and
Sarah proceeded to introduce all her
hallmates to the former president and
after a brief conversation the college
president assured President Carter to
the lecture but before he left Carter
leaned down and whispered in Sarah's ear
and said you owe me one Sarah
coming to college is about working out
who you really are some of the things
you've hoped to change about yourself
your discover are really not changeable
they're part of who you are some of the
things you thought you were certain
about about yourself those are the
things that might change this is the
time to discover which things about your
family your hometown your culture have
become a permanent part of you and which
will be left behind and some will be
left behind and the wonderful scriptures
we heard here today from the prophet
Isaiah and st. Luke's Gospel the prophet
and the Savior are also working on
identity they're taking a piece of what
God's people think they are and they're
using it to reinterpret who they think
God's people should be and the issue in
these two passages is the Sabbath the
commanded day of rest always a good
issue here at Yale where we really don't
believe that we're ever supposed to rest
I'm sorry to say Isaiah writing after
the Exile and Jerusalem says to the
people you think are observing the
Sabbath you think you're good righteous
people but you're really not even as you
go through the motions of the Sabbath
you're really all about your own
business the Sabbath God chooses is not
about your rituals it's about how you
live it's about not oppressing others or
judging others it's about not speaking
evil of others the Sabbath is not about
coming to a place and saying the magic
words the Sabbath God chooses is when
you take the food off of your own plate
and give it to the hungry it's when you
not only pray for or advocate for those
who are suffering but you actually go
and meet their needs that's the words
Isaiah uses you actually meet their
needs that God says is a Sabbath if you
do that God will be with you in the
tough times and in a wonderful phrase
Isaiah says you will be like a spring of
water that never fails God will make
your bones strong I love that it's like
vitamin fortified cereal
the the Prophet takes the Prophet takes
something that people know and uses it
to tell them something they don't know
so does Jesus on his way in the midst of
his long journey to Jerusalem he comes
to this village on the Sabbath and he
seems to randomly choose this woman
who's crippled she's bent over problems
possibly by osteoporosis when I was
missionary in India used to see women
who are literally 90 degrees bent over
at the waist and unable to stand so he
fought he sees this woman and he just
reaches out to her and he lays hands on
her and he heals her but one of the
religious leaders gets up and uses his
face about healing on the Sabbath and
Jesus gives it right back I love the New
Testament it's not at all religious it's
all about real life fights Jesus gives
it right back to this guy and he says
you untie your donkey and lead it to
water on the Sabbath but I can't unbind
this woman suffering what what's wrong
with you what's wrong with your idea of
the Sabbath Jesus and Isaiah's God is a
God of surprises just when you think you
know what the right path is and what
doing the right and holy thing is God
sends a prophet or a son to show you
that God's vision is unimaginably bigger
than your religion father John Shea one
of my favorite writer says that every
belief we have about God has literal and
a latent aspect the literal is what we
would say our belief is if somebody
asked us what the words are the latent
is how it affects our attitudes and our
behavior the synagogue leader doesn't
realize that his devotion to the literal
Sabbath may be standing in the way of
God's healing love the people of
Isaiah's Jerusalem can't see that their
literal practice of the Sabbath
disguises their systemic injustice it's
about both the things you believe and
the way you live them out even our
decisions about our religious identity
are
without unintended consequences lifting
up the god of victory may obscure the
God of peace lifting up the god of
personal salvation may undermine the
Gospels requirement of community shake
gives this long list he says things like
a theology that emphasizes God as king
may encourage mindless compliance to
Authority a theology that it's
emphasizes the suffering and death of
Jesus mace app the joy of creation out
of its inherent adherence the step
you're taking to Yale is a step into the
complexity of religious life it's not
Sunday school anymore and we invite you
into the daily struggle of this
complexity that belief has consequences
of all kinds and the belief actually
changes as we learn that it has negative
consequences sometimes in our lives
jesus said Isaiah want they're here is
to see that a good religious belief may
still have latent bad effects father
Shea has this wonderful line he says
when people hold a theology that
theology also holds them therefore we
must be careful what we put in our minds
when others who don't share our
Christian faith look at us what they see
is not the sincerity and beauty of our
beliefs I'm sorry to say they see what
we do to other people they see our
attitudes and our actions and no amount
of sincerity or beauty can overcome a
judgmental or an angry spirit what Jesus
in Isaiah point is to is a certain level
of suspicion about religion even within
religion and this is where it gets
really interesting it's a very Jewish
spirit and perhaps a very Protestant one
we need to test not only the orthodoxy
and coherence of belief not only what it
does for us but we need to also ask what
it does to us what dishonesty or
violence in my cloak too often religious
groups want to stifle all these
questions I remember when I was in
college I went to a couple of groups and
after just a few meetings you quickly
realize that some questions just weren't
allowed you weren't allowed to ask those
questions here no one ever says that but
the message is clear this church hopes
to be a place where all questions are
encouraged that doesn't mean I won't get
flustered when you ask I'm an introvert
takes me a little while to process but I
promise I'll get back to you with my
best answer in our daily struggles to
build our identities Christians are
called to have a discipline of suspicion
about their own identity as well Yale is
a great place to try on a full wardrobe
of identities academic juggernaut
activists on the barricades capitalist
socialist reactionary radical Nobel
bound scientist hipster artist bad boy
bad girl object of desire object of envy
object of fear as Christians we're
called to hold each outfit up to the
light and ask not only does this make me
look good but also does this make me the
person God sees in me not only does this
make me feel good but does this give me
inner peace not only is this cool but is
this right zayyan Jesus call us to lead
complex moral lives in a world that
wants simplicity and one line answers
not live for we seized hold of popular
or comfortable or safe identities lives
of inner struggle between the angels and
demons of our own desires between our
assumptions and prejudices and the
persistent quiet voice of conscience
between personal accomplishment and
success and justice and compassion for
the suffering Christ is in us and with
us most and best when we can stand back
from our identities and ask without
pride or self-hatred is this the life
God has
chosen for me and when I have the
courage to take that loving searching
deep and probing look at myself and
turned around and resolve again and
again and again to love God and love
neighbor not in theory or in doctrine or
in generalities but to love God here and
now in this day of my life in the midst
of my struggles and to love not humanity
in general but those I hate those I push
away those I'm afraid of if I can do
that than indeed I will be like a tree
planted by streams of water that never
run dry my light shall rise in the
darkness my bones will indeed be strong
we will be recalled we will be called
repairers of the breach and restorers of
Nations Isaiah says setting up our
identities whether we're 18 or 48 years
old is the spiritual task of our
lifetimes choose wisely what you put in
your head I think it was Quaker scholar
Parker Palmer who said our life's path
is less like an arrow in flight and more
like a character in a video game always
bouncing off obstacles taking new and
unimaginative Erick n I know I speak for
all of us here at the university church
when I say we look forward to praying
for you supporting you and encouraging
you in this amazing adventure